[Music]
tell us about your mom
the moms are such powerful figures in in
Catholic families yeah well your mom
also you said extremely religious Oh
I mean her Shh her Bieber was the Pope
like she went whenever he came to
Chicago I see her on the news jumping to
the crowd going like I mean she was the
sign of the devil by the way which would
be I would think confusing to the Pope
the Pope on the rope she the Pope plates
the Pope everything so she had a lot of
Pope memorabilia yeah which you can buy
did you have you ever did you if you or
your family ever been to the Vatican
they haven't because we were so poor so
but I got a chance when I was playing
the year some Italian designers hired me
to go to the Vatican when you were
Playmate of the Year you rank the to
mate of the year time to go to the
Vatican I desires hired me do like do a
party in Italy yeah and so when I got
there we were having dinner it was like
midnight and these designers said hey
you know the Pope's out of town and
we're connecting with the Vatican you
want to go in his apartment apartment
yes it's connected to the Vatican yes
yes so I was like are you kidding me
they said no we can let's go over there
right now it's going to check out his
apartment side the Vatican I'm like so I
was with two of my Jewish friends and
I'm like right so my Jews came with and
we pulled up behind the Vatican and this
holy like Igor comes out of the back aid
and they were been on and on and then on
that talking trying to get us in when
normally I would flash my boobs to try
to get in somewhere but this was not the
appropriate place and it might have
worked we've got we got in and it was
truly amazing I could never seen
anything like it there was these cherub
marble angels coming out of the ceiling
it was it was like I I felt so bad for a
moment because I'm like oh my god we
could feed a starving country with if I
cracked off one cherub head but I don't
understand who these guys that are like
I can get you into the Pope's private
apartment it
Italy it's Italy so we walked through
and he goes you want to check out his
closet it's like yeah he goes let's go
try some hats so we go in and this is
true we go in the Pope's closet no
describes literally what it look like to
you so I put them hat and I'm saying
they're going oh my god are you wearing
the Pope's out right now
this is crazy my mom is going to die so
I look at my choose and they're like
they're like looking at crosses crucifix
is going like what is this
so we wound up leaving and went back to
hotel room and I called my mom and I
could never believe this I was American
it's amazing and my two Jewish friends
go we took something for you out of his
closet and it was a cross they stole
from the Vatican wait a minute you you
went to the Pope's apartment and your
friends took something from the closet
they were Jewish they didn't believe in
Hell so that's why there's a long
Catholic tradition of blaming it on a
June
but I gave it to my mom as the president
and she still to this day until she
reads the chapter watches this tonight
does not know it is a stolen Christmas
so the police are closing in now the
police will come try to I did I don't
know I think they've got other stuff to
think about a lot of stuff they've got a
deal with got some problem I got to
mention something which it 20 years ago
hard to believe you posed for Playboy
for the first time and you've come back
and you have posed again 20 years later
and you look absolutely incredible yeah
were you riding a bike with those
fingerless gloves it's not no this is
just off attend a 10k ride yeah
what was the read you said you wanted to
go back and do this it was a little bit
of a cause
- and you look fantastic but we don't
Hollywood they always say you know by 35
girls are attractive you don't work as
much anymore so it's my kind of salute
to the milsat 40 like you know I'll send
up to 24 year old 5 year old we still
got it the mill still got it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]